[Music]
the math underpins everything in our
universe so it impacts every corner of
our society
but over the past decade in particular
the advances in computer technology and
introduction of machine learning and
artificial intelligence has been massive
and we're only learning more and more
and building better and better systems
and math underpins all of that and it's
fundamental to all of those systems and
in fact computer science is inherently
linear algebra so it's really
foundational to those scientific
advances one relatively recent example
that really inspired me was the first
real photo that scientists were able to
capture of a black hole
this mysterious remnants of giant stars
that lurk all over the universe
and it is the way the scientists use
creativity and math to solve the problem
that was so fascinating you see these
black holes are so distant that there is
no single telescope that is large enough
to be able to actually see them
and the scientists came up with this
clever idea creating a network of small
telescopes distributed all across the
globe that were synchronized to
capture and focus the same object at the
same time
creating a joint virtual telescope now
the aperture of this giant virtual
telescope is nearly the size same size
as the diameter of the earth
and with that in place the scientists
and engineers were able to capture all
the bits and pieces of data and put it
all together into the first image of a
black hole that is 53 million light
years which is
318 quintillion miles away now that's an
impressive use of creativity and math
[Music]
you